TWENTY FIRST MEETING OF
INSURANCE SAID TODAY WE HAVE
ONLY ONE BELL I DO SEE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE
WILL PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WELCOME MR DAILY. YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL. IT WAS ON
THE FLOOR AND YOU. VERY KINDLY
CALLED IT BACK HERE THIS
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE COULD TO
SUGGEST SOME AMENDMENTS. BASED
ON MY DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU. I
INTEND TO MAKE THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS WHEN THIS BILL
RETURNS TO THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE. TO INCREASE THE MINIMUM
NOTICE PERIOD FOR A NON RENEWAL
TO SEVENTY FIVE DAYS. TO
CLARIFY THAT VERY HIGH FIRE
RISKS OWN SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN
THE FARE PLANNED RIGHT OUT
CREDIT SYSTEM. AND REQUIRE THE
FAIR PLAN REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE ON THE AFFECTING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
CHANGES MADE BY THIS BILL TO
THAT RIGHT OUT CREDIT SYSTEM.
ALSO I'M ASKING TO ADDED
URGENCY CLAUSE WHEN THIS BILL
GOES TO THE FLOOR. AND WITH ME
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE FAIR
PLAN. OF WHO I THINK WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YES THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE THE FAIR
PLAN SUPPORT TO THE RIGHT OUT
CREDIT AREA EXPANSION. THE
REASON I'M SUPPORTING THIS IS
BECAUSE COMPANIES NEED ANOTHER
REASON NEED A GOOD REASON TO
WRITE IN AREAS THAT ARE HIGH IN
VERY HIGH FIGHTING FIRE DANGER
AREAS. AND BY PROVIDING A RIGHT
OUT CREDIT FOR WRITING. A
HOMEOWNER'S POLICY IN THESE
AREAS COMPANIES ACTUALLY ARE
GIVEN INCENTIVES RIGHT IN THESE
AREAS BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS THEY'RE REDUCING. THE
POTENTIAL FOR A LARGE
ASSESSMENT IN THE EVENT THAT
THE FAIR PLAN NEEDS TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT ACTUALLY MATTERS QUITE A
BIT TO COMPANIES AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD. FRANKLY
SUPPORT THE FAIR PLAN. OF
WRITING LESS BECAUSE THE
VOLUNTARY MARKET WOULD WRITE
MORE SO I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THE EXPANSION OF THOSE AREAS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT THIS IS MARGARET
WRECKAGE THE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND I
THINK HE'S HERE JUST ANSWER ANY
TECH QUESTIONS THAT MAY ARISE
IF I MAY I JUST FEEL AS WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA
TAKE. CARL FACE BEFORE WE
PROCEED THANK YOU RUBIO. HERE
RUBIO PRESENT JONES. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA PRESENT BATES BATES
PRESENT BURGESS JUST PRESENT
DODD. DOT PRESENT GALGIANI
GLAZER HUESO. HUESO PRESENT
MITCHELL MORLOCK MORE LIKE
PRESENT PORTANTINO ROUGH.
GALGIANI ROTH GEN PRESENT. WE
DO HAVE. YOU MAY PROCEED I KNOW
THAT YOU WERE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS ANY MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
MISTER MARLAND. JUST IN
LAYMAN'S TERMS COULD YOU DEFINE
RIGHT OUT CREDIT THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. QUESTION YES
I'M WE TEND TO GET OUT ON THE
INSURANCE STUFF SO IF THE FAIR
PLAN NEEDS FUNDS TO PAY CLAIMS
AFTER CATASTROPHE WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GO TO THE MEMBER
COMPANIES WHICH IS ANY ADMITTED
RIDER IN THE MARKET PLACE. ON A
MARKET SHARE BASIS AND REQUEST
MONEY FROM THEM SO WERE BACKED
BY THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY WHERE
IS THEIR BACK ME SIGA SO IF WE
NEED MONEY TO PAY CLAIMS WE GO
OUT TO THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
AND WE ASK FOR MONEY AND THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT EACH
INSURANCE COMPANY NEEDS TO.
SEND TO THE FAIR PLAN IS BASED
ON MARKET SHARE. BUT RIGHT OUT
CREDITS CAN. IF YOU WRITE IN
CERTAIN AREAS AREAS WHERE WE
WANT TO PROVIDE INCENTIVE I II
HI IN VERY HIGH FIRE DANGER
AREAS. THEY CAN ACTUALLY REDUCE
THEIR MARKET SHARE PERCENT. BY
WRITING BUSINESS IN THOSE AREAS
AND THE REASON THIS IS
IMPORTANT AS WE WANT TO GIVE
COMPANIES AN INCENTIVE TO WRITE
IN THESE AREAS. AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN A FINANCIAL
POSITION TODAY AT THE FAIR PLAN
WE ARE SITTING ON ABOUT THIRTY.
JUST OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S NOT MUCH MONEY. ONE
CATASTROPHE WERE DOING AN
ASSESSMENT COMPANIES CARE ABOUT
THIS SO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO GIVE THEM INCENTIVE TO WRITE
IN THESE AREAS WHICH WILL THEN
REDUCE THE AMOUNT THAT THEY
WOULD THEN HAVE TO PAY US. IS A
WIN WIN IT HELPS THE CONSUMER
BECAUSE THEN THESE COMPANIES
WILL WRITE IN THESE AREAS THEY
WON'T HAVE TO COME TO THE FAIR
PLAN. CERTAINLY HELPS THE
COMPANY THAT HAVE TO GIVE LESS
MONEY TO THE FAIR PLAN AND
CANDIDLY HELPS THE FAIR PLAN WE
WRITE FEWER POLICIES WHICH. I
WORK IN OPPOSITE WORLD WE'RE
TRYING NOT TO WRITE POLICIES
SO. AS I EE ITIT'S A WIN WIN
SO THOSE RIGHT OUT CREDITS.
IT'S AN INCENTIVE FOR COMPANIES
TO WRITE IN THESE AREAS WHERE
WE WANT THEM TO WRITE. AND THEN.
WOULD THEY HAVE TO RAISE THEIR
PREMIUMS TO WRITE OUR. KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN LET'S SAY A
COMPANY HAS 10% OF THE MARKET
SHARE IN STATEWIDE BEFORE WE DO
THE ADJUSTMENT FOR THE YEAH
RIGHT CREDITS LET'S SAY THEY
WRITE A FULL 1% OF THAT 10%
PREMIUM IN THESE AREAS. WITHIN
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF AN
ASSESSMENT THAT THEY WOULD BE
ASKED TO PAY ESTáN HOW MUCH
PREMIUM THEY WRITE IN THOSE
AREAS SO AGAIN IT COSTS THEM
NOTHING IF ANYTHING COMPANIES
WHO ARE ACTIVELY WRITING THESE
AREAS WILL BENEFIT. FROM LOWER
ASSESSMENTS FROM THE FAIR PLAN.
SO IT DOESN'T BUT IT DOESN'T
COST ANYBODY ANYTHING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME. MR DOT. DID YOU HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION QUESTION. ONE
A ONE YES THE OTHER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MANAGER OF I AM
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS AND
IT IT IS FANTASTIC BECAUSE OF
THE FCT THAT WOULD BE HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
POLICY WOULD WOULD COVER THE
DWELLING AND NOT BARNES OUTSIDE
AREAS ONLY THE- DWELLING ITSELF
IS THAT CORRECT. ARE YOU
REFERRING TO THE FAIR PLAN
POLICY ITSELF IT JUST DEPENDS
ON WHAT IS SCHEDULED ON THE
POLICY SO WE CAN COVER
OUTBUILDINGS IS ONE OF THE
OTHER. YES AND ALSO THE FAIR
PLAN DOES GO INTO AREAS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT.
PERHAPS THERE'S A MIXED USE
THEIR WAR IT'S AN OLDER
PROPERTY THAT THE FARMERS
ALLSTATE STATE FARM WOULDN'T
TOUCH. BUT THE FAIR PLAN WOULD.
ARE WE INCREASING THE RATE FOR
THEM AND COVER THEM AS WELL. WE
WILL WRITE IN THIS IS WHAT I.
SAID THIS MORNING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THE FAIR
PLAN RIGHTS WHAT THE NORMAL
INSURANCE MARKET WANT. THAT'S
REALLY THE WAY TO LOOK AT IT IF
THEY WON'T WRITE IT WE WILL WE
ARE THE BACKSTOP IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR PROPERTY
INSURANCE THE PURPOSE OF THE
FAIR PLAN IS TO MAKE SURE. THAT
ANYBODY WITH INSURABLE PROPERTY
MEANING THERE'S NO LIKE ON
REPAIR DAMAGE IT HASN'T BEEN
VACANT FOR TOO LONG THAT THEY
CAN IN FACT GET INSURANCE
THAT'S THAT'S OUR ROLE IN THE
MARKETPLACE. GOOD THANK YOU
WELCOME ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MASTER FORTRESS. THANK YOU JUST
A VERY MUCH A BASIC QUESTION.
ONE MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
DIRECT NEXUS SO IF THE
INSURANCE COMPANY. IS WILLING
TO ISSUE POLICIES IN. PRONE
AREAS HIGH RISK PRONE AREAS. IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT TAX CREDIT THEY HAVE
TO IDENTIFY THAT IT IS FOR
THOSE PRONE AREAS THOSE
ISOLATED AREAS YOU CAN'T BE
DISTRIBUTED ELSEWHERE IN THE
STATE IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT SO THE CAL FIRE MAPS
OUR GEO CODED AND WE WOULD
REQUIRE THAT COMPANIES THEY
HAVE TO SUBMIT TO THE FAIR PLAN
ON ANNUAL BASIS. OF WHAT ARE
CALLED RIGHT CREDITS WE
ACTUALLY GET POLICY LEVEL
INFORMATION AND WE WOULD THEN
CONFIRM THAT EACH POLICY THAT
THEY SENT US DATA FOR IS IN
FACT. WITHIN THOSE AREAS BASED
ON YOUR COAT. GREAT SO HOW IS
THE EVALUATION OF THE TAX
CREDIT. BORN INTO IN CALCULATED
BY THE INSURANCE PROVIDERS IS
THERE ANY DEGREE OF OVERSIGHT
THAT WERE EXPECTING TO BE DONE
BY FAIR THAT WOULD IDENTIFY
THAT. THIS IS COMMENSURATE WITH
THE TAX INSTEAD OF THE
RECEIVING I'D I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY TAX INCENTIVE THAT
THEY'D BE RECEIVING WATCHING ME
THE CREDIT EXCUSE ME YET WE
WOULD WE WOULD VALIDATE THAT.
SO EVERYBODY HAS TO SUBMIT DATA
TO US ON AN ANNUAL BASIS IF
THEY SO CHOOSE NOW RIGHT
CREDITS OF COURSE ARE. A
BENEFIT TO THE COMPANY BUT I'M
NOT ALL COMPANIES CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE WERE HOPING
CANDIDLY THAT THE EXPANSION OF
THESE AREAS WILL INCENTIVIZE
MORE COMPANIES TO NOT ONLY
WRITE IN THESE AREAS BUT THEN
CENTERS THAT DATA BUT THEN WE
WOULD VALIDATE THAT DATE. NOW
IN LLOYDS OF LONDON. DID THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO. THE FAIR PLAN OR
THE INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION. DO YOU MEAN VIS A
VIS AN ASSESSMENT OR MY
QUESTION IS SOME OF THE LAST
FOLKS THAT USED TO ISSUE
POLICIES AND HE'S PRONE AREAS
AND I ONLY JUST BRING OUT AND
TOTALING. LLOYDS OF LONDON WERE
THEY PARTICIPATING IN IN THESE
PROGRAMS THE ONLY THE ONLY
COMPANIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THIS ARE THE- A LIMITED
INSURANCE COMPANIES SO LLOYDS
OF LONDON IS NOT AN ADMITTED
INSURANCE COMPANY SCOTTSDALE
AND VOIGTS LONDON WERE NOT.
CORRECT SO THE LAST TWO ISSUING
AND- THE FOOT HILL MOUNTAIN
TERRITORIES MY UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THAT COULD BE I AM THE
FAIR PLAN OF COURSE THEM OKAY
LAST QUESTION IS HOW DO
SOMETHING AT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND START IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE I GET UPDATED. IF
YOU DID MANAGE TO GO UP TO
MILLION FIVE. AND THE GOOD NEWS
IS WE ARE INCREASING OUR LIMITS
TO THREE MILLION. WERE YOU
SHIFTING GEARS TO THE GUARANTEE
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS HERE.
COLLEGES FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TO A MILLION. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO A MILLION FOR
PURPOSES OF HOMES PLUS THE
ADDITIONAL ALIY AND CONTENTS SO
IT'S ACTUALLY A HIGHER THAN A
MILLION NUMBER AND HOW TO TAKE
ALL THE WAY UNTIL NOW FOR
ANYBODY SAID. THAT DOESN'T WORK
FOR HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
ANYMORE I THINK TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU MERCED CASUALLY TO
HENDERSON PERCENT CASUALTY TO
FOR US TO FIGURE THAT OUT THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THAT AFTERNOON ANNA
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT WE SEE THIS
AS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT
WILL INCREASE STERN INSURANCE
AVAILABILITY IN OUR STATE THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON STACY HE
WROTE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA R. C. R. C. ALSO IN
SUPPORT AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED SEVENTY FIVE DAY
AMENDMENT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON SIR AND
TELL THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA. WE
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THE
HOMEOWNERS ARE FACING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WITH THE
SIXTY DAY NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT. AND WHILE SEVENTY
FIVE DAYS WOULD PUT CALIFORNIA
ON THE OUTER EDGES OF THE TIME
FRAME NATIONALLY. WE RESPECT
THE INTENTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR AND THAT DOES NOT
CHANGE OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR-MEMBERS YOUR MEMBERS ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SIXTY DAYS
FOR THE NOTICE PERIOD THE
SEVENTY FIVE DAYS MISTER TAYLOR
SAID PUTS US ON THE OUTER LIMIT
LITTLE BIT HARDER FOR
MEMBERSHIP BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT
NOW IN CALIFORNIA SO WE REMAIN.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IS
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SO I DO
UNDERSTAND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ONCE
SAID TESTIFY AT NIGHT I'M
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY YOU'RE NOT
TAKING A POSITION BE ONE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES. GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. COULD SEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE MARTINEZ
RUBIO FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
BRIEFLY TESTIFY HERE IT IS TRUE
THE DEPARTMENT AND IN
TRANSMISSION DOES NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS RECENT
VERSION OF THE BILL. WE HAVE A
PREVIEW OF THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
ON THIS MEASURES IT CONTINUES
TO MOVE FOR THERE ARE THREE
ELEMENTS. TO THIS BILL. THAT WE
DO A VARYING DEGREES OF
PERSPECTIVE ON. SO THE FIRST
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
IS THE INCREASE FROM FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND LIMIT TO ONE
MILLION. WE DO SUPPORT THE
ELEMENT OF THE BILL WE THINK
THAT IS CERTAINLY LONG OVERDUE.
AND AGREED TO THE RECENT MERCED
CASUALTY INSOLVENCY THAT WE SAW.
LAST YEAR WAS REALLY WAS. OF
THE MOST RECENT EVENT TO OCCUR
THAT UNDERSCORED THE
INSUFFICIENT. LEVEL THAT. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WOULD HAVE FOR
MANY HOME PROPERTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHOSE REPLACEMENT
VALUE IN INSURANCE COVERAGE
EXCEEDS THAT CAP UP AGAIN AT
THAT POINT IN TIME SO WE
SUPPORT THAT ELEMENT OF THE
BILL. ONE OTHER ITEM IS THAT
THE SB NINE A ONE COMMISSION ON
CATASTROPHIC WHILE FOR COST
RECOVERY ALSO RECOMMENDED THE
INCREASE FROM FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE MILLION. IN ITS
JUNE TWO TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT
FROM EARLIER THIS YEAR SO
WANTED CAN BE THAT DOCTORS THAT
PARITY. SECOND ELEMENT IS THE
FAIR PLAN RIGHT OFF WE ARE
GENERALLY SUPPORT OF THE INTENT
OF THAT WE ARE A AND HAVE BEEN
TALKING ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD BE COMING OUT. ON THE
BILL AND AS THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS BRIEFLY POINTS OUT ON
PAGE FIVE. OF THAT INSURERS
THAT THERE ARE YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL CONCERN THAT INSURERS
COULD CHERRY PICKED THEIR
CREDIT SOME SHOW A PREFERENCE
FOR HIGH RISK AREAS OVER VERY
HIGH RISK AREAS AND SO AS A
RESULT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
MONITOR AND REVIEW. INFORMATION
FROM THE FAIR PLAN ON HOW THE
RIGHT OUT CREDITS ARE USING THE
NEW SYSTEM PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL BY ENSURING ONLY THE
LOWEST RISK WE REALLY WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. THE INTENT
BETTER THE AUTHOR HAD HAD SET
OUT. IS ACTUALLY IT'S
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVED IN THIS
PARTICULAR ELEMENT OF THE BILL
SO AGAIN THAT'S SOMETHING NOT.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AND
IT'S CLEARLY WITH THE FAIR PLAN
REPORTING BACK. THAT WE AS THE
INSURANCE REGULATORY WILL
CERTAINLY LOOK TO. TWO WOULD
VERIFY AND ENSURE THAT THAT
DATA IS UP STANDING INCISIONS
REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT. AND
THEN THE THIRD ELEMENT OF THE
BILL THE THIRD AND LAST IS THE
NON RENEWALS AND THE DEPARTMENT
COMMISSIONER WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GENERAL DIRECTION. OF
THE BILL WITH HOPEFULLY MORE TO
GO WE UNDERSTAND WE APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHOR AND- ACCEPTING NOW
THE SEVENTY FIVE DAY NOTICE
AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR CONSUMERS
TO SHOP THE THING THAT ARE A
DYNAMIC THAT THE COMMISSION THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE MANY. A TOWN
HALL MEETINGS THAT WE ARE
HAVING THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
HAVE HAD THESE LAST SEVERAL.
MONTHS IS THAT IT'S A POINT OF
CONSIDERATION IS THAT AS MUCH
TIME THAT THE THAT WE BELIEVE
THE CONSUMER SHOULD HAVE SHOULD
THEY BE NON RENEWED OR THE
NOTICE OF. NON RENEWAL IS GIVEN
TO THAT POLICY HOLDER THAT WE
WANT THEM TO HAVE SUFFICIENT
TIME OR AS MUCH TIME AS
POSSIBLE TO. BE ABLE TO SHOP
FOR ALTERNATIVE INSURANCE
POLICIES IN THE ADMITTED MARKET
PLACE AMONG THE SURPLUS LINES
OR AMONG THE FAIR PLAN. THERE'S
ANOTHER ASPECT THAT ADDITIONAL
TIME WOULD GIVE IS ACTUALLY TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE TIME. TO THAT
HOMEOWNER TO MITIGATE THEIR
PROPERTY THAT SOME INDIVIDUALS
MAY NOT KNOW THAT IT'S ALSO THE
TO TAKE THE TIME TO SHOP. FOR
AN ALTERNATIVE POLICY IT'S ALSO
TIME FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE THEIR PROPERTY REMOVE
TREES OR BRUSH AND ACT
STRUCTURAL REPAIRS. MOVE
PROPANE TAKES AWAY FROM THE
HOME REPLACE ATTACK WITH NON
COMBUSTIBLE MATERIALS AND CLOSE
THE VENTS THIS THAT TAKES TIME.
AND AT TIMES THAT OF CURRENT.
UNDER EXISTING LAW FORTY FIVE
DAYS CAN BE. ON A INSUFFICIENT
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
WANTING TO EXTEND AMOUNTS FROM
SIXTY DAYS AS PROPOSED IN THE
BILL TO NOW SEVENTY FIVE BUT
THAT WE ALSO FEEL THAT THERE
SHOULD BE MORE TIME THAT WE
SHOULD CONSIDER AND THAT THE
COMMISSIONERS ALSO HAS BEEN
PROPOSING ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS TO BE CONSIDERED SO THAT'S
WHERE WE WANTED AT LEAST
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE ON THIS
PARTICULAR ELEMENT. BUT IN ALL
WE DO APPRECIATE THE BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU. KILL AS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
THIS EXPRESSED CONCERNS I KNOW
WE HAVE. A TWEENER A CD I
ANYBODY ELSE I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THE CONCERNS. NOW. OKAY
WITHOUT MEMBERS ANY OTHER
FURTHER QUESTIONS. SO WHAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH CAN YOU
PLEASE EXPRESSED TO OUR
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER THAT
THAT WE APPRECIATE HIS CONCERNS
AND DOWN JUST FOR EVERYONE TO
UNDERSTAND MISTER DATING I DID
SIT DOWN WE DID DISCUSS ALL THE
CONCERNS AND DIE AND I KNOW
THAT FOR US WE WERE. TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING NOW TO TRY AND
HELP SOME OF THOSE FOLKS THAT
ARE STRUGGLING AND WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO HAVING DISCUSSIONS
FURTHER IN THE COMING MONTHS TO
ADDRESS THAT THE NUMBER OF DAYS
BUT THE REASON WE WENT FROM A-
SIXTY TO SEND IF I WANTED TO
ADD ANOTHER MONTH FOR FOLKS TO
BE ABLE TO SHOP AROUND AND I
KNOW IT'S NOT EXACTLY WHAT
EVERYONE WANTED BUT- IT'S A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO
I FELT THAT. AT LEAST FOR NOW I
WANTED TO GO THAT EXTRA MONTH
AND SO WITH THAT FEES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER DAILY JUST
TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE.
COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. WE ARE COMMITTEE
STAFFS CORPORATION WE HAD A TWO
HOUR HEARING THIS MORNING ON
THE FAIR PLAN AND ONE OF THE
INTERESTING POINTS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FAIR PLAN MADE
IS THAT MANY FOLKS WHO. BUY
INTO THE FAIR PLAN WITHIN
MONTHS. UGH CONTINUE SHOPPING
AND BUY ANOTHER POLICY AND DROP
THE FAIR PLAN SO IT IS A PLAN
OF LAST RESORT BUT IS NOT
NECESSARILY PERMANENT NOR IS IT
ALWAYS IDEAL FOR THE HOMEOWNER
BUT IT IS THERE AS A AS A
PRODUCT OF LAST RESORT SO IT'S
SO IT'S WORKING PRETTY WELL I
HOPE THAT THESE TWO WEEKS WILL
MAKE IT WORK EVEN BETTER. THANK
YOU THANK YOU OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE ALL OF
YOUTH AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR INPUT AND I BELIEVE HAS
TRIED TO LET HIM OF THE BILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONSIDERATION RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE JONES JONES I
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA AYE BATES
BATES FIVE FOUR JUST FOR JUST
AYE DODD DODD AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HUESO. HUESO ARE YOU MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK MORE LIKE I
PORTANTINO. ROTH ROTH I. THE.
SO AT THIS TIME OR IN A PLACE
TO BELONG PAUL I BELIEVE
THERE'S A FEW MEMBERS THAT ARE
STILL STUCK IN COMMITTEE UNTIL
FAN I BELIEVE IT HAS TO GET OUT
ELEVEN VOTES AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT SHOULD WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CAN BE FOUND THE
SERGEANTS. THEY SHOULD BE DOING.
YEAH I JUST. AND I WANT TO LET
HIM KNOW
. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
CURRENT PHONE IS ELEVEN ZERO
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I. ARE
GOING TO GET A LIVE THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU
. WE WILL NOW LEFT A CALL TO
ACCOUNT FOR HALF THE MEMBER. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FOR
CONSIDERATION CURRENT VOTERS
TWELVE ZERO. MITCHELL. HI
MITCHELL AYE THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU AND THIS. DURING THIS
MEETING THANK YOU EVERYONE HAVE
A GOOD DAY